we have some breaking news we can bring
you now this is about a legal challenge
the government's plans to deport some
migrants to Rwanda while the high court
has upheld the home office plans this
has been rumbling on in the courts for
quite a while the government has argued
that it should be able to deport people
that it chooses to to Rwanda while their
applications are assessed a number of
different legal challenges to this
decision have happened over the last few
months which has delayed the plan it's
not a single person has been as yet
deported to Rwanda under this scheme
we've got some words from the court Lord
Justice Lewis says it is lawful for
government to make arrangements to
relocate for Asylum claims to be
determined in Rwanda rather than the
United Kingdom he goes on to say it's
consistent with Refugee convention
however he also said the Home Secretary
must consider properly the circumstances
of each individual claimants particular
circumstances and also said that the
Home Secretary has not probably
considered the circumstances of eight
individual claimants so the cases have
been set aside and referred back to the
Home Secretary so it is complex but
essentially the government have been
told that they can Deport people to
Rwanda but the eight people that have
brought this legal challenge are not
automatically going to be deported to
Rwanda because in the judge's view their
cases haven't been considered
individually in enough detail so the
government will have to now reconsider
all of their cases in Greater detail but
the judge appears to have said that in
Broad principle the principle of the UK
government deporting people to Rwanda
while their Asylum claims are determined
is lawful